the six series convertible is a car for
all seasons and a real joy when hunting
down the last rays of summer sunshine
especially in this edition with its
extra long hood set back cabin position
and extended wheelbase
car reviewer sophie
finds the rear view somewhat obscured by
the roof she recommends the optional
rear view camera
fortunately the weather plays ball
meaning that sophie can quickly put the
top away and out of sight
the roof can be opened or closed while
driving at speeds up to 40 kilometers an
hour
now the open top 6 series can really
show its sunnier side adaptive
suspension enhances the ride comfort the
slightly concave trunk lid creates light
and shadow effects
the bi-xenon headlights likewise have a
charismatic look
the front section's distinctive
appearance is further defined by the led
daylight running lights
sophie's first impression is pretty
positive it's big comfortable and a
four-seater altogether pretty slick in
her eyes this is a dream car
the low-lying and slightly protruding
kidney-shaped grille plus the sweep of
the hood set the car sights firmly on
the road ahead
the designer brigade at bmw sought
aquatic inspiration for the exterior
this convertible has flowing water
contours all over
the flat extended body and the wide rear
give the car power and character
the roof seen here in fast mode needs 19
seconds to open up
closing takes 24 seconds
with the top open chrome trim guides
your eyes across the car
the rear windshield is practical says
sophie and can also be raised with a
roof down it's made of glass and has
built-in heating she finds this car more
of a two plus two seater due to the lack
of space for rear passengers
if you do insist on sitting at the back
there's help in the shape of automatic
seat adjustment
the front cabin features aluminum trim
and is arranged around the driver in
typical bmw style
the 640d convertible is standard fitted
with an eight-speed sports automatic
transmission leather seats that reflect
sunlight mean that passengers get a
comfortably cool welcome even on hot
days
and you'll need a cool head behind the
wheel with this kind of acceleration 630
newton meters of torque push the car to
100 kilometers per hour in 5.5 seconds
and give it a top speed of 250.
the new 640d convertible has a stiffer
suspension and its wheelbase is now
seven and a half centimeters longer
you have a variety of driving modes
available there's comfort for a gentler
ride
for more aggressive outings switch to
sports mode the gears are then held
longer and the steering is more direct
after a day out in this luxury
convertible sophie sums up the sports
model
the maker claims the 640d convertible is
extremely economical burning up 5.6
liters of fuel for 100 kilometers
sophie's experience suggested a figure
closer to 8 liters this is still a dream
car for her though although with a
starting price of 87 000 euros it's
likely to remain just a dream